Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more
people taking calls today via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's
hear next from. How about Rick from southeast
Texas? Rick from southeast Texas. Welcome
to the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Welcome. Thank you
so much for having me. Thank you. So, hey,
my question is regarding, well, of course, you
know the current state of U. S politics. What
else? What else could I talk about? So my
question is, you know, with George Santos,
I wrote a little something in my notes, but it's
a little outdated now. I thought that he was going
to resign, but of course, he doesn't have spine,
so that doesn't work out. And so. Do you think
that there is a possibility with the slim majority
that you know, whether it be through? Unintended
deaths or resignations. Do you think that the
Democrats could retake the House by just that?
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know about that. So. So,
I mean, we've got the Santos resignation that is
maybe going to happen. I don't know. It seems like
pressure is sort of starting to loosen on Santos
a little bit. But I don't know the the math of the
other stuff. You're saying there could be way more
unintended deaths among Republican members of the
House than Democrats. And maybe that could shift
the balance back to Democrats, because remember,
with a lot of those, if someone dies in office,
I don't remember. Is it the governors that get to
appoint a temporary replacement, in which case red
state governors would just appoint Republicans?
Again, I just don't know that that makes sense.
I'm not sure I'm understanding how it would work.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess I wanted to relate it
kind of. What were you been talking about?
Prior episodes where obviously Republicans
are less prone to get vaccines, although we know
congressmen, Congresspeople are probably smart
enough to lie to people, but get the vaccine
behind their back, which, you know, we know
it's going. We know what's going on. And so I
was thinking maybe that could play a factor. I
was just thinking, you know, you're more educated
than a stern graduate. And so I just went. So I
just wanted to, you know, that's all I wanted to
say. I just wanted to make sure that, you know, I
was just kind of thinking about that. And I don't
know, I that's what I say, all of those things.
Speaker 1: I think the issue with all of these
things is that they often become a replacement
for just figuring out how to win elections. And
to that extent, they are a distraction. You know,
if some Republicans are going to die and somehow
it'll make Democrats in the majority for some
brief period until the next election, you can't do
anything about that unless your suggestion is to
go out and kill Republicans, which obviously
you're not doing, and neither am I. I just
think it's like there's no point in even really
wasting too much time thinking about it. Let's
focus on winning the next election, you know?
Speaker 2: Absolutely. No, I'm right there with
you. Thank you so much. My pleasure, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Rick from
southeast Texas. Great to have you. Why don't
we go? Why don't we go next to Sal from Malden,
Massachusetts? Sal, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hello, David. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, Thank you for asking.
Speaker 3: Hi. So I was just calling
just to see if you had any or if you
knew anything about this current case,
about an Angie Diaz murder
case? No. Have you heard of it?
Speaker 1: Have not heard of it.
Speaker 3: Oh. Okay.
Basically, it's just about a woman who was
married with a citizen, United States citizen.
There is a lot of background where it
looks like they may have done it due to
immigration purposes. So. Relating this to just
immigration policy. I find that there's a lot of
issues going on with immigration. That's and that
seems to stem from United States intervention.
Do you think that the United States
or. If this should be proposed
to give those coming from Central America affected
by US policy, basically providing amnesty for
people affected from United States intervention.
Speaker 1: You're saying the U.S. takes some
action that, for example, affects
people in Guatemala. As a result,
the U.S. bears a responsibility and should
then offer amnesty to Guatemalans who are in
the U.S. illegally.
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 1: And and is it to all Guatemalans
in the U.S. illegally or only Guatemalans in
the U.S. illegally as a direct result of
the American intervention in Guatemala?
Speaker 3: The second.
Speaker 1: The second thing. I mean,
listen, I don't know how you actually do something
like that. The truth is. So the U.S. already
has a process for asylum seeking based on the
circumstances in one's home country. And those
requests are, you know, adjudicated through a
process. It sounds like what you're saying is
if the reason for the asylum can be shown
to be a direct result of American policy,
then a sort of priority is given and they
are definitely granted asylum. I mean,
I think it's interesting. I think it's
completely impractical and unlikely to
happen. But I do think that morally it's a
very interesting issue that you bring up.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I tend to lean more on
the blind amnesty just because I read a
lot about Latin America. But that's a definitely
interesting take. David and I just had a second
quick question. More on the production of The
David Pakman Show. Sure as then. Okay. Yeah.
So just random, the music that you
used to have in between segments. Yeah.
Have you ever thought of bringing that back?
Speaker 1: You know, not really. And mostly the
reason is that music generally causes copyright
issues. We also needed more time. That was when
we needed to fill time for affiliates for
a particular reason that the kind of right
now what we've done over time is instead
of having 40 minutes of content per hour,
we now have 55 minutes of content per hour.
And part of that is that we got rid of that
music. So it would only come back in in in lieu of
content. And I don't think most people want that.
Speaker 3: Oh, okay. Yeah. Oh.
Speaker 1: But I would rather 12
minutes of music instead of me talking.
By all means, let me know. You know, So.
Speaker 3: Maybe they should
release a David Pakman album.
Speaker 1: Maybe so. Maybe so. All
right, Sal. Good to hear from you.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, there we go.